The one thing I would have
to have an immediate bias
was towards the Middle East.
I identify as transgender,
non-conforming.
It's not often assumed
that I am part black.
Do you think that being gay
is a choice?
I can't be sure.
Who should police the police?
The citizens.
That actually scares me.
If I had to have a conversation
with my kids about this,
I wouldn't know pretty much
where to start.
How I treat
and talk to my children
is very much reflective
of the environment that
they walk into every day.
I'm a lawyer by trade.
- I better watch what I say.
- (chuckles)
I've been a cop for 20 years.
We must understand that
how we've been weaponized,
you know, against
the black community.
Hello, everybody,
my name is Jesse Williams.
I want to welcome everyone
joining us today
as we discuss bias,
conscious and unconscious bias
and its impact on us
personally and the collective.
I am here now
because I feel like
we're experiencing
a real opportunity.
The real opportunity is
in the public consciousness
with all that's happening in
the world and in our nation.
We are primed, I think,
to accept the possibility
that maybe we have some
room for improvement.
Maybe there are some things
that we can learn about
ourselves and each other
that will allow us
to grow forward.
So part of that is
acknowledging conscious
and unconscious bias,
the roles that we might
be playing
in this whole equation.
I think it's incredibly
important for us
to face it, talk about it,
be open to that possibly.
Everyone has bias,
myself included.
It is a real issue and it's
something that we can address
and just learn more about.
It doesn't make anybody
inherently wrong.
It's something that's
worthy of exploring.
So over the next few hours
we're going to do just that.
We're going to watch
a series of conversations
between complete strangers
meeting for the first time,
and they're going to discuss
not only themselves,
but issues that bring up
the concept of bias
in their lives.
This might be
uncomfortable at times.
It certainly has moments
of discomfort for them.
It might for you as well.
Feelings could be hurt.
But that's part
of the process.
That's how growth happens.
So amidst that discomfort,
these are all opportunities
for learning for us.
So before we dive deeper,
I do want to acknowledge
how we've come here today,
that can't do that without
thanking Procter & Gamble
for spreading the word
and spearheading this effort.
That also includes BuzzFeed,
who's allowing us to use
their platform,
so thank you so much.
For years P&G has been
using their voice
and acting as a leading advertiser
to shine a light on inequality,
highlighting bias in particular
with their recent work
in the last couple of years
and sparking a dialogue
to promote understanding,
to promote action.
So I'm not going to do this alone.
We are going to dial up the
incredible Freddie Ransome,
who is a content creator,
has a lot of insight
around bias,
and she's going to help us
walk through this
whole experience
and be a great asset
to us today.
Hey, Jesse, how are you?
I'm great, how are you?
I'm good.
I'm excited for what
today's going to hold.
Just to give everyone
a little bit more detail
about the ins and outs
of this experiment,
we've paired 14 strangers
together to talk about bias.
And these are real people,
they are here because
they want to have dialog
and they want to experience
some personal growth.
So please be respectful
to them in the comments,
even if you don't agree
on what they're saying
because we're all
friends here,
we're all just here to learn
and take in new information
or just sort of spread light
and share light to each other
in regards to experiences
and personal biases.
It's interesting when talking
to new people or strangers,
I think folks can relate
to being at a party
or a new gathering,
you just find yourself kind
of pouring your heart out
to somebody you just met.
I think the idea that
won't definitely follow you
in your social circle
or your family events,
you've got a little bit
of freedom
to just kind of
unload something,
to explore something,
experiment,
play around with ideas
without it being
kind of attached to you
like this static cling
and you're going to have to be
accountable for it later.
We all carry with us learned
assumptions, presumptions,
we all are a byproduct of media
and marketing and information
and cartoons and commercials.
Also, now is a good time
just to let folks know
it's not only Freddie and
myself participating today.
We are really lucky
to have an absolutely
brilliant professor,
Dr. Charisse L'Pree,
sharing her incredible
talents and wherewithal.
Professional L'Pree is at
Syracuse University
where she currently focuses
on how the media affects
the way we think about ourselves,
exactly what
we're talking about,
our perceptions
of ourselves and others.
We've been working with her
to bring an added layer of context
and facts into this discussion,
those pesky things
that are necessary.
Beyond just watching,
we're going to be posting
discussion prompts
in the comments,
so pay attention to those
if you could.
This allows us all to be able
to join the conversation
from an informed perspective.
So be sure to
add your thoughts
and questions
there as well.
This is a safe space, so please
don't succumb to any habits.
We've all been in
comment sections
and we can see how it can get
childish and ugly quickly.
Let's elevate today,
let's make that a safe space
so we can constructive
conversations.
And now, while we have
paired strangers together,
they're not entirely random.
We intentionally went about
this in a curated fashion
to encourage discourse beyond
their echo chamber.
These have been
really expansive,
long conversations
when we've paired
these strangers together,
so we've naturally had
to edit them down for time.
We did that in
the most responsible way.
So in order to catalyze
these conversations,
we have passed along P&G's
award-winning short film
called The Look
to all of these pairings
so that they can
watch it together
and it can be a great way to
spark conversation about bias.
Let's start with
our first pairing.
We have Chozy joining us
from Atlanta, Georgia,
and we have Lynn
in North Carolina.
So we have them dialed up
and meeting each other
for the very first time for
an interesting conversation.
All right, let's do it.
Hello.
Hi.
How 'ya doing?
Well, I'm well
today and yourself?
I'm going great, just excited
about this experience.
Isn't this something?
My name's Lynn.
Lynn?
Lynn.
Hi, my name is Chozy.
Oh come on, no.
[sighs]
Um, I can definitely
relate to the beginning,
getting the weird looks
for looking different.
I can't believe this stuff
still happens
and I know it does
and I cannot understand why.
[sighs]
Yeah.
We still judge each other on
the way we immediately appear.
Where do you think
that comes from?
The reason I think a lot of
people think that way,
which is not only in the U.S.,
it's a global thing,
is just lack of interaction
with people that are
different than you.
I am originally from
East Jerusalem, Palestine,
and I came here in 2001, three
weeks before September 11.
So, when I came here I was
saying, "I'm Middle Eastern,
I'm Palestinian, I'm Muslim,"
and it is just who I am.
I didn't think anything of it.
So September 11 happens
and all of a sudden
there is this hate
for anybody
that looks Middle Eastern.
So if you're brown,
you're going to be a target.
It doesn't matter if you're
Arab, Indian, Hispanic,
mixed black and white,
just dark featured,
and a lot of people got
harassed and
attacked on campus
at Georgia Southern.
And I was like I'm not going
to go out and say
that I'm Middle Eastern.
I'm going to have to dodge it,
lie it, try to be a chameleon.
But it's hard to
be a chameleon
when the majority
is black and white
and nobody looks like me.
What I'm hearing you say is
that it comes
from non-exposure
to different types of people
and they're visually different
and we have to
judge immediately.
The one kind of group that
you can see my ignorance,
I think when I thought about
biases towards people,
the one thing I would have
an immediate bias
was towards whatever
I would call;
and you're right, it's ignorance,
the Middle East.
Because it's different and so,
as we've had more immigrants
and as I've been able
to meet more people,
you see, my views change.
And this is the only way
that we can break down
these conclusions.
It's kind of embarrassing here
to admit that
I've had these biases.
It's embarrassing.
But I have not
really been able
to interact very much with
people like yourself, Chozy,
so I don't know
how the universe knew
that you're the person
I probably needed
to talk most to.
Yeah.
I've been in churches here
when I came to the U.S.
and I've been to
Baptist churches.
And I'm looking
around and I see
this poster of a white person
that looks like Kurt Cobain
from Nirvana
with blonde hair, blue eyes,
on a cross.
And I'm like, "Who is that?"
And he's like, "This is Jesus."
And I'm like, "What?!"
Jesus is from Bethlehem.
Jesus was a Jewish person from
Bethlehem in Palestine.
If you go to Palestine right now,
nobody's blonde hair, blue eyes.
I'm considered light-skinned.
People are a little bit
darker than me.
Yeah.
I don't care what the Census
says that we are.
I'm not treated like I'm a white
person when I come to America.
I'm accepted by blacks
more than whites.
Where I grew up in
Northern California,
there was a lot of dissension
with black people.
We didn't even have anybody
from Palestine or Jerusalem.
We didn't have Jewish people.
And I drove through the
part of town that was black
and because I was white,
they threw a rock at me
because they were angry.
And that was when integration
was starting
and they would bring black
children and white people
and white children together.
We're people and we're
doing the best we can,
and it's not real good.
But if we keep talking about
it and meeting each other,
and if I can see your pain,
and maybe you can see
my embarrassment,
because that's just who I am
and I'm still trying to change.
Let me let you picture this.
Four hundred years ago you've
been brought to this country
in shackles, enslaved.
Let's say they traded
your people for money.
They gave you freedom,
but everything you ever
built they will burn
and they always
will make you
feel like you're
the bad person.
So no matter what you do
and how high you get in life,
you will still be that slave.
How would you feel?
Would you throw
a brick at somebody?
[sighs]
I would probably try
to burn everything down
because it's so unfair.
It's so unfair.
I really honestly feel if
I had been at the scene
where George Floyd
was being killed,
because I'm a little
white woman,
I probably could have
jumped in there
and they would have been busy,
because I'm not a threat.
It's called, "white privilege".
The police
don't see me as a threat.
I've been pulled over and let
go and they've said to me,
"If you were black I'd take
you in, but you're not."
How do we change this, Chozy,
how do we do this?
People need to be aware of
their white privilege.
During 9/11 I was walking
back to my dorm.
I don't know what's going on.
I've been in America
for three weeks.
I walk in.
I'm looking at the big TV
in the lobby.
I see a building on fire,
people jumping and chaos.
And I'm like, "Oh, this
looks like back home."
Why?
Because we see this every day,
this is nothing new.
So from that day on,
Middle Easterners and Muslims
have suffered ten times
more till this day.
And they burned mosques,
they killed Muslims,
they banned Muslims from
coming to this country.
Well, I thought this country
is based on freedom
to worship any, you know,
to practice any religion.
I'm very moved
by your description
of exactly how
you were treated, Chozy,
and the ignorance
that makes me cry.
It makes me
really embarrassed.
But things are changing,
people are moving all over
and we need to help people
like you change it.
Actually change begins
with people like you
that are thinking about
these issues,
but still not taking action.
The smallest
action you can take
is, number one,
surround yourself
with people that are
different than you.
Number two, talk to people,
your family,
know how to talk to them
with having a constructive
conversation
that can have criticism and
some defense and offence.
But we have to
unite the people.
We have to put our
differences on the side.
We can't just keep bringing
biased and prejudiced
and racist things that keep
dividing us.
I'm so moved by what
you said, Chozy,
and I understand that
the actions that I take
are to talk, to be aware,
but talk to people especially
as I meet them.
Because I'm probably
not at all what I appear
and I didn't tell the producers
that, you know, I'm gay.
And certainly I've had
beer bottles thrown at me
and I have not wanted
to bother anybody,
I just wanted to be left alone
and be myself,
whatever that is.
And I've pretended a lot
because I can get away
with pretending.
So you're with a woman?
Yes, sir.
Okay, so you
didn't mention that
so I'm glad you mentioned
that because—
Well.
—then you would have
kind of experienced
a lot more of what
we experience.
I never really said too
much about it
because I just felt like
it's nobody's business
and, honestly, I lied about it
because I could.
I mean you can't see that I'm gay.
As I've grown and seen
the things that
people have gone through
and the way that gay men
were treated in the '80s
with the AIDS epidemic
and losing so many people
that were my friends
and no one cared,
it does make sense
that if I had really stood up
and copped to the whole
thing and made a stand
and said, "No, you don't treat
people this way
because these people are me
and if you like me, then
you like gay people, right?"
But here in Hendersonville,
North Carolina,
I've been actually
legally married
and that is
a form of acceptance.
And I have nephews and nieces
who have grown up
and they don't think
a thing about this
because of their exposure
to people that were gay
and they go, "Well, so,
what's the big deal?"
I thank you for sharing
that with me
because that's part
of who you are.
There's no way to see
that or tell that,
so that was
a pretty interesting twist
and it kind of changed
the whole aspect of this call
because I knew then
I can definitely relate and
make you relate mostly
to what I've been feeling
and have empathy as well
for what you've
been going through.
And I know this struggle
because I'm from
the Middle East;
and we're not open for that.
And my cousin is gay.
He thinks he tries to make
a noise about it
so he can get the equality
and the freedom,
and I want you to do the same.
So I had this epiphany
while you were talking
that this is how bias changes
is that you've had this
conversation with me,
and maybe you'll be
with somebody
or your family in one way,
and they'll talk
about something.
But you've had this
experience; you'll go,
"Well, you know
there was this time
I talked to this woman,"
and believe me, if I see
anybody from Palestine
it's going to be,
"Well, you know
I talked to this
man and he was
from Palestine
and he's in this country
and this is how he feels."
I want to thank you,
Lynn, for doing this
and I want to also thank you
for sharing with me
and being able
to listen and respond
and have a very healthy
conversation.
Thank you.
Well, Chozy, I think the best
part about talking to you,
while I'm sitting here realizing
that, oh, I just came out
to the entire world
and I did because of you
and because of what you
and the people
that produced you
have been through
and you made me understand
[gasps] the pain.
And you've helped me
really immeasurably.
Look at all the things I said.
I owe that to you, sir.
I do.
How about that?
Go figure.
Thank you, thank you.
Thank you.
Okay, so that was
Chozy and Lynn;
really a little plot-twist
towards the end.
I know for me personally,
when I was watching the video
I was not expecting her
to say that she was a part
of the queer community
and that she's married
and has this whole other part
to her story that we were—
at least I was unaware of
at the beginning.
So that was kind of interesting.
And I think also,
kind of in real-time
this bias is sort
of playing out.
It's like I'm thinking like,
oh yeah, she's cis,
heterosexual, white woman
who, like you know,
probably hasn't really
experienced a lot of turmoil
in terms of identity.
And that's just me making
that assumption
and then to find out
that, oh, actually
she has experienced this.
Okay, now I'm getting a better
understanding of who she is.
Yeah, what was interesting to me
was how it impacted
Chozy immediately.
It always makes folks
feel more comfortable
having conversations
with people who can
or are willing
to understand them,
whatever that means,
and a big part of that is
a shared actual experience.
Parents talking about how
hard it is to have children,
they can relate to actual
parents much better
than some single person
with no kids, right?
Exactly.
It's really that basic.
So when Chozy thinks
he's talking to somebody
who kind of fits
all the dominant boxes,
most of them outside
of gender,
to hear, well, you actually
have to deal with identity,
with making yourself small,
with making yourself quiet
with not always
identifying yourself
in a way that would
make you a target,
okay, we're actually on closer
footing than I thought,
that makes me see you
slightly different
or maybe feel more comfortable
expressing my experience
in a way that has a better
shot of being received.
I think you watched
Lynn certainly,
for lack of a better term,
kind of mature and grow
and settle
into her comfort zone.
Yeah, you love to see it.
And I can say, too,
I was really happy that Lynn
was self-aware
in the fact and confident
in admitting
that she lied about
her sexuality for years
because she knew
that she could.
She could sort of slide
under the radar
as outwardly I guess presenting
as a straight, white woman
walking through the world.
And that was interesting
because I think that
that sort of transcends
in so many different scenarios
whether you can pass race-wise
or ethnically or in terms of
religion, sexuality.
I think that we all could
come to the table
with certain areas
where we can pass
and we sort of use that
for survival.
I don't necessarily think
that it's that she's ashamed,
but a lot of times
it's about safety.
So that's something
that stood out to me.
A couple things that I clocked,
not because they were new
but actually
because they're fairly common
in my lived experience
is what bias can do is it can
minimize or isolate
the experiences of others.
While Chozy explains
some of his experience
in the discrimination
that he goes through,
I mean can you imagine
being a Palestinian
landing here three weeks
before 9/11
in Atlanta, Georgia
[gasps]
—the fear that he has?
How do you go out
and get coffee?
Every day you're going out
and you could possibly be—
we saw hate crimes
obviously skyrocket.
And as he described
some of this,
you see what I've seen commonly
I imagine you have
as well Freddie
is this kind
of incredulousness
from your white acquaintance.
I had no idea,
totally either blind
or reflectively
presenting themselves
as blind
to the lived experiences
of those around us.
Oh, no way,
can you believe it?
I had no idea something
like this would happen!
And so it's the combination
of distancing,
minimizing that experience,
whether consciously or not,
and then making the burden
of solving it
on the person of color.
It's sort of the whole idea
that racism is an issue
that the marginalized
community has to solve
or it's like a black issue
or an Asian issue
or whichever
community that is.
And it is not.
It is a white issue,
an issue of the oppressor
and of those with privilege
and those in power.
Yeah.
All right, so let's move on
to our next pairing
and it's going to be
JC and Garnet,
both of whom are currently
based in Arizona.
Hello?
Hi.
Hi, my name's Garnet.
I'm JC.
Hi, JC.
I love your outfit.
Thank you.
Where are you located?
I'm in Arizona.
Where you at?
Oh, that's where
I'm currently safer at home.
Really?
Yeah.
Now we're getting stared at.
Okay, now as this individual,
I'm very nervous.
That was scary.
Yeah.
We're in court?
Are we the attorney?
I don't know.
Are we the judge?
Are we the jury?
Oh, please let
it be the judge.
Oh, thank God.
Yes.
[snaps fingers and laughs]
[chuckles]
What got me the most
was the moment we were
in the courtroom,
my mind thought,
okay, they're bringing out
the defendant and it's his P.O.V..
I was viscerally relieved when
that wasn't the case.
Yeah, automatically I'm like,
oh my God, I'm nervous
and I'm nervous because
I hope that this person
isn't going to get prosecuted
for incorrect reasons.
So I think I was trying
to compensate with like—
I hope he's the judge,
I hope he's the attorney,
I hope he's the jury,
so I could also like breathe a
sigh of relief from it as well.
I think that I'm not immediately
identified by other people,
especially people
who are white.
It's not often assumed
that I'm part black.
It's just assumed
that I'm not white,
which is not quite the same
especially now.
For most of my adult life,
I had a shaved head.
I used to get extra security
screenings, pat-downs,
taken out of line,
questioned in the back room
with no windows all the time.
And I was basically being
racially profiled.
And it wasn't because
I was part black.
It was because I looked
Middle Eastern.
And my mom said,
"You need to shave
your hair."
My first instinct was like,
yeah, that's a good idea.
And then my next reaction was,
no, that's the opposite
of what I want to do
because that would mean
I would be taking
one more visibly
at-least-part-black individual
out of the situation.
And that's exactly what people
who hate black people
want to happen.
They just want
fewer black people around.
Yes, your hair is political!
[snaps fingers]
- [laughs]
- And I can relate to a lot of
what you were talking about.
I also traveled a lot
as a flight attendant
for the past six years.
- Okay.
And I also was getting profiled
a lot as like Middle Eastern.
And I've had pretty
serious altercation
with one pilot in the cockpit
that was treating
me really horribly
and they basically
were pinning me
to the inside
of the cockpit door
and it was just so, so, so
scary [laughs] to have that.
That's tough.
I'm sorry to hear that.
I'm 25 percent black
and I'm 75 percent white.
I'm not American,
I'm actually Canadian.
But it wasn't until
I arrived here in the U.S.
that people started to regularly
recognize the black part of me
and mostly that
were other black people.
And so I started to—
I would go get my hair cut,
I would always seek out
like the blackest barbershop
because whenever I walked
into a place like that,
there was never like,
"Who's this beige guy?"
[chuckles]
"What's he about?"
They automatically were like,
yeah, this guy's part black and
he's part of this community.
I identify as transgender
non-conforming.
I basically wake up
and every single day
is a little gender-reveal
party to myself.
[laughs]
Really?
Because I just like
go with the flow.
I feel like today I'm like,
"I'm feeling more masculine,
I'm feeling more feminine."
But when I would go to work
and have to wear
a uniform with a tie,
I would purposefully find
like one or two things
to "express my gender,"
whether that was the woman's
purse or something.
And I would get constantly
asked by coworkers like,
"Is that really—
are you allowed to do that?
They're not saying
anything to you?
They're not
writing you letters?"
And I'm like, "I'm wearing a
bag, the same bag you have,
so why— like, no."
Yeah.
And it was really frustrating
to have to constantly validate
my gender or like myself
or even have to explain,
especially to folks
who didn't really want
to be educated about it.
They were just
sort of projecting
their own views onto me.
That would be
really challenging,
definitely challenging.
I mean I was in my early 20s
and I had a roommate.
And it was around that time
That I started
to sort of come into
feeling out being part black
and wanting to embrace
that part of myself
because, up until then, I hadn't.
I read Malcolm X's autobiography.
I even went and saw
Louis Farrakhan speak.
I was just exploring.
And he kind of confronted me in
a way that I wasn't expecting.
And this is one
of my best friends.
He said, "Why are you
reading that?"
or, "Why are you getting into
all of this like black stuff?"
And I was like, "Well,
you know, I'm part black."
And he's like, "Well, you're
only 25 percent black,
so why don't you just get over it
and embrace the majority
of yourself, which is white?"
And I was really angry
because the fact is that
you only have to be
a little bit non-white
for people to see you
as not white.
And that can really, for lack
of a better word,
"color" your experience
in the world.
Exactly.
When you are in white spaces
And you talk
about your blackness,
how is that received?
That's a good question.
White people always want to ask
what my background is.
[gasps and laughs]
Oh, God!
Yeah, same.
Where are you from?
You're like, "Oh, well,
originally I'm from Calgary."
"Where are your parents from?"
- [laughing]
- "Oh, well, my dad's from Calgary
and my mom's from Manitoba."
They're like, "No, but where
are they really from?"
And I'm like, "Oh, I see, you're
wondering why I'm not white."
Because they want to get
to what race I am,
where do I fit into their idea—
Yep.
—of who I should be
or what I represent.
I understand exactly
what you're saying.
Was there ever a time in your
life when you found yourself
either suppressing
a part of your identity,
whatever that may be,
in order to make a social
situation or any situation
easier or more comfortable
for everyone in the room
kind of thing?
I was like 12 or 13 years old
and I just wanted to be like
a Manic Pixie Dream Girl
that sits on countertops
and is cute and weird,
and I just wanted
to be that for myself.
So I was expressing myself
in that way
and I remember
these men in my family
pulled me aside and they were,
"You're acting feminine
and you need to like macho-up
because you're turning
into like a young man,"
and blah-blah-blah-blah.
That's the way it felt,
oh my God,
I'm doing something wrong
and this really hurts my
family and I'm being shameful.
And that moment
got internalized for years,
like 10, 14, whatever years.
Even if I'm trying
to just change my diet,
I feel like I have to like almost
feel ashamed of my lifestyle
as I explain it to my family.
And it comes from
just years and years
of never getting my needs met
or being seen as who I am.
Mm.
Yeah.
And this might strike you
as, I don't know,
I don't know how
you're going to take this.
But a time when I've suppressed
something about myself
is I like karaoke.
Yes!
[laughs]
And when I was in Toronto,
I was a karaoke host
for a long time, full time.
And the best place that
I hosted at was a gay bar.
Yes.
And when I worked there,
I found myself inwardly
embracing the fact
that maybe people
thought I was gay
because I happened
to be hosting
a karaoke show in a gay bar.
And I was happy about that.
This actually brings up
an important question
that I think is relevant,
how do we consume and
appreciate and amplify voices
that need to be heard without
being appropriating
and/or gaining anything from it.
Because as an ally,
clearly I see you as an ally
for LGBT community,
especially working
and hosting in a gay bar
and being super
comfortable in there.
But in what ways has your
white passing experience,
how has that
showed up for you?
I worked in a place
that was a very high-level,
private-members club.
I don't even think there
were any black members.
And I was witness to people
talking about things
that were blatantly racist,
like telling N-word jokes
and stuff.
I'm standing right there
and I'm thinking to myself,
oh, they don't realize
I'm part black.
And so at the moment,
I just didn't say anything
because I didn't want to have
that confrontation
in that environment.
I want to just do
a quick little example I had
from when
I was a flight attendant.
And I was in the back of the
airplane and we were in flight
and all of a sudden
I heard some music
or something happening
in the cabin
and I instantly went to this
black couple to go ask them
to turn off their phones or
their speakers or whatever.
And when I went there
they had nothing
and then I was like,
"Excuse me,"
and then they just
looked at me
and they're like, "What's up?"
And I'm like, oh my God;
I just did something
that was super biased.
It just really showed me
the bias that I had.
I was just so inappropriate.
JC, let me ask you a question.
Why do you think bias
is dangerous?
I don't think bias itself
is necessarily the danger.
It's not recognizing that you
have bias that is dangerous.
That eventually trickles down
to resentment and then to hate
and then to extreme actions
that are just inexcusable
and dangerous
for so many folks.
Do you think that knowing
that people have conscious
and unconscious biases
do you think it's possible
for people to overcome?
Not only do I think
that it's possible
for people to overcome
their biases,
I think people's lives
depend on it right now.
People need to recognize
their own bias
in how they can show up
and fix those biases
for literally the survival
of black people.
They can no
longer just show up
by posting pictures
on Instagram,
even walking in marches.
It's like do this now because it's
important right now in history,
but do this from now on and
call it out when you see it
and call it out within yourself.
And also don't take
offense to it
because you learned it
somewhere,
but now you can unlearn it.
And after you do that,
you have the opportunity
to change as well.
Well, and I think you're right.
And I think it's more important
to talk about, firstly,
our own bias,
our personal bias,
because calling someone
else's bias is easy to do
but it also creates confrontation.
But I think if people witness
one another
acknowledging
their own bias,
I think that will open up
the ability for people
to have more sort of truthful,
honest dialogue about it.
And it's sort of coming
from the 'me'
rather than coming
from the 'you'.
Yeah.
Well, I think this was
a very interesting experience.
I want to come away
from this dialogue
with a more open mind
and open heart to strangers
and not automatically
pass judgment on them
and just learn from them and
see what they're all about.
My biggest takeaway is maybe
how do we structure that?
And I actually think
the video was helpful
in terms of opening up
a dialogue.
It just really opened up the
door for all these avenues
for our own experiences
to come through
and it was really cool.
Yeah, if we're not that far
apart, maybe I'll bump into you.
[laughs]
Yeah, maybe I'll see you
at the grocery store
or something.
[LAUGHTER]
All right, bye.
Bye.
[LAUGHTER]
All right, well, that quickly
became one of my favorite
conversations of the day.
JC and Garnet spoke to a whole
variety of things actually,
half of which that I can
absolutely relate to
and trigger experiences
of my own
in terms of ambiguity,
in terms of race
and labeling and people's need
to know what you are.
And I also learned a great deal
and appreciated JC
kind of checking in
with Garnet about
a couple of things
and talking about allyship
versus appropriation
and how to be responsible and
thoughtful in that process.
Yeah, I mean first of all,
they were so cute.
It was such a pleasant
conversation and I was like,
oh, like I hope they become
actual friends after this.
Right.
Also, they're local so, yeah,
it's actually doable.
Exactly, yeah.
And I think they were both
incredibly respectful
and they had a lot
of I think similarities
in some of their experiences
of both living—
or I guess
sort of being ambiguous
in how they present
gender-wise
and also, you know, racially.
So I think that this was a
really productive conversation.
Right, yeah, very much
highlights ingroup/outgroup
and the role that that plays.
I mean folks
are making comments
because that's how they feel.
And we often check
our surroundings,
"boys will be boys"
locker-room conversation
is probably different
in the locker-room
with a bunch of cis jocks
than it would be
at Thanksgiving dinner
with a whole panoply
of other folks.
So we constantly check.
We have our inside/outside
conversations,
ingroup/outgroup conversations.
There's a default to what are you?
And this is coming from somebody
who my entire life probably
the most common question
that has been asked of me,
the most popular three
words to me is,
"What are you?"
since I was very little.
And it's in the first five
sentences of many interactions
since I was little,
"What are you?"
And what is that question?
Why don't we talk
and you'll find out what I am,
because represent themselves
through their actions.
But you need some kind of
label in order to categorize.
It's not always ill-intentioned,
but it's definitely annoying.
And for both of these folks,
it was nice to see them
have a shared experience
because they probably don't get it-
who am I to say,
but it's possible
they don't get it very often.
Garnet certainly seemed like
he doesn't often get to relate
to people on that level of
what it's like to be ambiguous
and always need to be labeled.
There is also I think
is worth mentioning
a difference between ambiguity
and looking like
you're a person of "color"
versus being black.
Anti-blackness is so specific
and it's filled with such
vitriol and tradition,
in this country at least,
that it kind of stands on its own.
And by "kind of" I mean definitely.
I was looking at some
of Professor L'Pree's notes
and she was saying
that based on some
very specific research,
it is proven that when strangers
are walking about in the world
and we are passing each
other on the streets
and standing in line
behind each other
at restaurants or et cetera,
like those who are
ethnically ambiguous
get started at way longer
than those who you're able
to easily categorize
and put in a box.
And I wanted to know like
have you ever found yourself
when you're walking
through the world—
aside from because of the fact
you're Jesse Williams
and you are well-known,
but even before then,
have you ever experienced
really noticing people
glaring at you
or knowing that someone
is really trying
got figure you out?
Absolutely.
In my entire childhood
coming up,
especially because I lived
in entirely black areas,
entirely white areas, entirely
poverty stricken' areas,
entirely kind of lower-middle
class and big—
and we have a lot
of very insulated
pockets in this country
and I've lived in many of them
and have not fit in any of them.
So, yeah, I've been the object
of that kind of staring.
And because they don't know,
derision often comes with that.
I resent the fact that you're
making it harder for me.
It's worth noting also
just that JC rightly
pointed out to Garnet
we should be thinking
about how to be an ally,
how to be a productive ally
without appropriating culture
and making sure you are
still your authentic self
without kind of dibbing
and dabbing
and sampling cultures without
actually having any interest
in the roots of their history
and how they're impacted
initial a multitude of ways.
All right, let's go into another
one of our conversations.
This one is between Marlee
and she's talking to Renee.
Hello?
Hi.
Hi!
How are you?
I'm great. How are you?
Good, I'm Marlee,
nice to meet you.
And I'm Renee, nice
to meet you as well.
So I've seen that happen.
I mean even in L.A., as liberal
and progressive of a place
that we think we live in.
Well, it's nothing new to me,
nothing to us.
And it's something that
we've come to expect,
something that we experience a lot
and basically pretty
much all the time.
And it's a shame because it's
based on what we look like.
You could have all
the degrees in the world,
but it has nothing to do
with any of that.
You know, I went to high school,
there was like one black
family in my hometown
and there was a lot
of that happening.
It happens every day.
You see it every day.
I found myself breathing hard.
My heart started beating fast
because it's so typical
and it makes me angry.
When we go into a store,
it doesn't matter
how well-dressed we are,
sometimes we're followed
immediately, we're assumed.
And it bothers me, it really does.
And it's so unfair.
Yeah, I just want
to say to that, Renee,
that I'm bothered for you
and it makes me so angry.
There's so much
that I'm learning
and unlearning that I realize
just being born white
and with a certain privilege
and where I grew up
that there's so much
that's just innate
or learned behavior
that you're learning.
And unlearning and I'm trying
so hard to just grow
and break the cycle.
And it's like I just hope that
we can keep moving forward.
Marlee, you know what I appreciate.
And I think this is what
touches my heart so much
is that at least
there's a willingness.
And that's what I hear
so much from you,
there's a willingness to listen,
finally a willingness to listen
when, for so many years,
it seemed as though
if we mentioned
something like that,
you know, the looks, the stares,
what are you talking about?
What are you talking about
somebody looked at you?
For some reason,
we weren't believed and the
curtain has been pulled back
showing the truth of our lives,
the truth of what we've had to
experience for so many years.
It's so true and I was protesting
a couple of days ago downtown
and this black man
stopped me and he—
because we were holding
"Black Lives Matter" sign—
and he's like,
"It starts with you guys
who are here willing to fight,
put your bodies in front of us
and just like stand up."
Because I had
a similar experience—
and this is the only way
I can relate where—
I'm never going to understand
and I know that
because of my skin color.
I am very androgynous
in the way that I dress
and express myself
and I've gotten threatening
looks and those vibes.
I know what you're saying
where it's hard to explain
to people
like what are
you talking about,
where I've felt threatened
because people are afraid
of the unknown.
They're afraid
of what they don't know,
so them trying
to figure me out,
is she a boy, is she a girl?
I was followed
into a bathroom last fall
because they thought
I was entering
the wrong bathroom
for my assigned gender.
And that was
the first time I felt fear.
I was shaking, and I'm shaking
just talking about it
because I was like who's this
person to come in here
and tell me that I'm not using
the right bathroom
just based off of how I look?
But I have that default
of like I'm white
and, as scared as I was,
I didn't think they were
going to shoot me.
I'm never going to know
to that extent.
It's frustrating,
you see on Facebook
and I have a mixed bag of
progressives and conservatives
because of where I'm from
and there are still
so many people
that it hasn't clicked in
in saying "All Lives Matter."
It just shows me that
we have a long way to go,
but you're right, it's a start.
Why do you think that
they don't get it?
Is it because
they don't want to
or do they think
that we're less tan?
I wish I could
understand that.
I think it's everyone is
trapped in their bubble
and doesn't have
enough exposure.
They don't have friends
who are of color.
Yeah, you can be nice
to someone a person of color,
but that doesn't mean
you have racist thoughts
or, like in that video,
you're not going to roll up
your window.
They don't see
who you are  at work
versus who you are—
I know I'm a different person
at work than I am here at home
with my girlfriend and my dog.
I feel sorry for them.
If they knew me,
they would recognize
that I am a human being
just like they are.
They would recognize I'm a
child of God just like they are.
Why are we so hated
in this country?
It makes me
angry and it hurts.
And I have grandsons
that I worry about.
(voice breaking) They're
sweet as they could be.
And to have to worry
about them
not coming home one day,
that's the hardest thing
for any mother.
And then to hear George Floyd
to call for his mama?
I don't have kids.
I would like to someday.
I was just wondering
if you could expand
a little bit on that,
how that resonated with you
when George Floyd
did call out for his mom.
I think that, as a mom,
I think that is
the greatest joy I think
that I have ever had
was to have children.
And it's just a miracle to me.
It doesn't matter
what color you are,
the fact that you have this child
that you carried under your heart.
So I mean you would do
anything to protect that child.
To take it maliciously like
that in front of people
and your child is begging
for their life,
begging "I can't breathe,"
it's just unbearable.
There are no words, Marlee,
there are just no words.
There's just so much I think
that we have to help people
to understand.
How do you think you can,
going forward,
help some people understand?
I think I just need
to be more willing
to have these uncomfortable
conversations,
especially with family.
It's so much easier for me
to not combat
what they're saying
to make it easier for me.
But if I'm making it
easier for me,
I'm not making it easier
for you or people of color.
So I know that I need to start
calling these people out
and it's a lot of energy,
but it's worth the energy
if people are being murdered
in cold blood.
Hey, Marlee,
you said something
about when you're at work
that you hide your true self,
something like that.
What was that about?
When I started working
in the film industry—
I work in the art
department primarily—
there was a lot of men,
older men when I joined.
And I'm androgynous and I look
like how most Cali boys look
with long blonde hair.
They would assume sometimes
on my first day at a new job
that I was just some young guy.
There were some times
where I felt like I had
to hush my voice
or not speak until spoken to
so that they didn't hear
the tone of my voice
or the high pitch
because I felt like
they're going to respect me
first for being a man.
Like if there's something
I don't know how to do
because I'm new,
they're not going
to judge me like,
"Oh, because
she's a young girl."
What made you decide that you
wanted to be androgynous?
Looking back now—
and like I said,
since I've moved out here
there's been so much more that
I've discovered about myself,
in gender, in being queer,
in playing on the gender spectrum.
I have this vivid memory
of when I was little.
I remember my dad
and my brother
were outside playing.
My dad was mowing the grass.
My brother and I were
playing with the ball.
And they both had their shirts off.
And I kept pulling my
shirt off and my dad's like,
"No, you can't do that."
And I just didn't understand
why that was taboo.
That's how I feel now.
I've had so many issues
with body dysphoria
and ways that I feel about
feminine parts of my body
that I just now have discovered.
But looking back
there's been incidences
that were always there.
And it was definitely difficult.
I was like the black sheep
of my family.
I definitely got
made fun of a lot
because people just
did not understand that.
I've recently learned that the
black LGBTQIA community
is disproportionately
marginalized.
Do you have any insight
as to why that is?
Well, you know what, Marlee?
You're going to have to do
me a favor, okay,
because they keep adding
letters to that.
So would you do me a favor
and break down
the new letters, please?
Lesbian, gay, bisexual,
transgender,
queer, intersex a-gender.
I came out as a lesbian
when I was like 20.
I started to discover
these parts of me
and realized it was
always there,
but it was just
kind of suppressed
because of the area
that I grew up in.
Even my family,
it was hard for them
because even though, like I say,
they're pretty progressive
and open-minded,
it always comes down to,
well, when it's your own kid
it's like a different story.
So I was just kind
of circling back
just because I've been seeing
so many parallels
in my own personal growth
and struggles or obstacles
that I've had to face that,
like I said, it's not comparable
in a sense that I will ever
fully understand,
but I think it's helpful in this
learning and unlearning process
of trying to draw your own
experiences as close as you can.
Back in the '60s,
we didn't really talk about
that until I got older.
We didn't talk
about those things.
Do you agree that
homosexuality is
a sin or not, you know—
The way I was raised in
the word from adulthood
is that homosexuality
in and of itself
the lifestyle
of homosexuality is a sin.
And in the Bible it does say,
"That a man shall not lie
with a man."
So according to the Bible,
the Bible says everyone has
to live out their own salvation.
You are going to live your life
according to the way
you decide to live your life.
I'm not going to judge you.
That's not my place.
[laughs]
Do you think that
being gay is a choice?
I can't be sure.
I really can't be sure because
I don't understand—
just like you say
that you don't understand
what it's like to be black
and what you've experienced—
and to be honest with you,
they are not the same thing.
They're not.
Being homosexual
and being black,
I can't even equate
the two things
because they're not
the same thing.
But my not understanding
homosexuality,
I don't know if it's a physical
thing, a spiritual thing,
a psychological thing...
I have no idea.
I can tell you that, for me
personally, it's not a choice.
There's been times with people
not understanding sexuality
or my gender where there's
been so many times
it's like, if I just
didn't feel like this,
of course I would
choose the easier route.
I would choose being straight
because that's how society
is more accepting.
I guess if we were ever able
to meet in person
and you saw someone give me
the discriminatory look
or made a comment to me
about my identity,
would you stand up for me?
Absolutely, I would stand up
for you, Marlee, absolutely.
No one has a right
to discriminate
against anyone, anyone.
No one has that right.
Yeah.
And not just me, but I guess
or someone like me
or especially people in
the black LGBTQ community.
That's right.
No one has that right.
Thank you.
It's just crazy that we've
never even met and don't—
and people are going to think
this is like a plug,
I'm like we've never met.
- [laughs]
- But already just in
these two hours
I feel so connected to you
because you have been
so open and willing to hear
things that I've struggled with
and I'm just beginning
to only learn of the things
that you've struggled with.
But you've been willing
to listen and learn
just like I'm willing
to listen and learn.
And it's just really refreshing.
It is refreshing.
And I think that's the bottom line.
I think we have to be open and
willing to listen and learn.
It doesn't mean that we're
going to agree on everything.
Right.
[LAUGHTER]
- Awesome.
- Thank you. Take care.
- Talk soon, bye.
-Bye!
So that was a really
unique conversation.
They were both
really respectful.
I think it was productive.
I think from jump initially
when Renee was explaining
sort of her reaction
to watching The Look
and saying—
she said she found herself
breathing hard
and her heart
started beating quickly,
once they entered
the courtroom,
it's so interesting
because I completely relate
to those feelings
when I'm in those types
of uncomfortable situations.
It's like this visceral—
these body reactions that I get
that are subconscious
and I don't realize that,
oh my gosh, I'm
actually soaked
because I was sweating
out of nervousness
for walking past this cop
or something like that.
And even Marlee brought up
that she also
experienced that
when she was walking
into the restroom
and realized that she had been
followed into the restroom.
And then her body just
had this reaction
because it's just like
this very specific reaction
that I would be
so curious to know
like white people who check off
all of these boxes of power,
do they ever really experience
these body reactions?
Sometimes I think we get
into a bit of a suffer-off,
like a competitive suffering,
like measuring
who's had it worse.
There is a difference
between saying,
"I can relate to having
that feeling,
I've gotten that feeling
when this has happened
in a coffee shop."
But it's different than saying,
"I know exactly what that's like."
What I did appreciate was
when Marlee was explaining
her experience of having
those body reactions
and a little bit of fear
when she realized
that she had been
followed into the restroom
was that she said that
she was really scared,
but she acknowledged that she
wasn't scared for her life,
which is a key difference in
I think the two experiences.
And I think that it was
really beneficial
and productive for her
to validate her feelings
and acknowledge that
this is how she felt
in those moments, but
that it is also not the same.
Yeah, that's exactly
how it should be done.
You can have a relation to—
you can let somebody
know they're seen
without making it equal.
And I thought it was
interesting in Renee's answer,
if I have this right, Marlee
asked about how she'd feel—
"Renee, how do you feel?
Do you think
that it's a choice,
do you think that it's a sin?"
And if I have it correctly
I feel like Renee answered
not from the outside
how she thinks,
but what she was taught.
Taught.
Which that shows itself
in other conversations
that we're going through today
too is a bit of a pivot
from really receiving
the question
kind of flush but saying,
"Ah, well, what I was
taught was this."
Which is fine,
it's important to know,
but it's not the answer.
It's not really confronting how
I feel and I wonder why that is.
Renee is very similar
to a lot of the older black
women in my family.
- You know what I mean?
- Sure.
Who are still trying
to figure things out
and me having to explain
what non-binary is
and all of these things
to the older black folks
in my family.
So it's one of those things
that can be frustrating
if you're not willing
and open to learn.
Totally.
Especially, in fairness,
that is an ever-changing world
of nomenclature
and I don't want to put people
off from being curious
with this kind of cancel
culture, that was offensive,
because I want folks
who are absorbing this
to feel like they
can ask questions.
Find a way to
do it respectfully.
Maybe don't go
"they keep" just saying,
"Hey, I feel like
I may not be updated."
Yeah, I think in general
my takeaway
from Renee and Marlee's
conversation was that it was
more of sort of like that
generational push and pull
based on keeping up
with what's happening
in the LGBTQ community
and also what's happening
in the black community.
Renee as a mother,
really touching as a mother
and being concerned that your
child will return safely home
and won't be killed or beaten
at the hands of those
in privilege and in power,
a.k.a. the police.
So I think there were a lot
of different topics
that were touched on
with this conversation
and I kind of wish
it could have gone longer
because I think that there was
a lot more to unpack,
especially on Renee's end in
learning more about Marlee
and the queer community
and things of that nature.
Yeah, I would add I think that
Renee, even after the call,
I would hope that she sits
with the challenges
that were put before her,
the difference between
what I was taught
and what I actually think.
And maybe you don't know
what you think in that time
because now you're actually
faced with somebody.
All right, Jesse,
so our next pairing will be
Judy who's based in Texas,
and Martin who's based in Illinois.
This one was a doozy.
[LAUGHTER]
Stop what you're doing
and watch this video.
Please watch
this one, you guys.
I think it's important not
only because of what happens,
but because we know folks with
a lot of these perceptions
and we know the impact
they can have.
So without further ado,
we give you Martin and Judy.
Hello.
Hi.
How you doing?
Judy, is it?
I'm Judy.
What is your name?
I'm Martin.
A little bit of background
about me.
I'm married.
I've been married since 2002.
I have four boys
and they range in age from
34 all the way down to 8.
How old are you?
Now you're getting personal.
No, I'm 54.
You don't look like you should
have a 34 year old.
Oh, no, no.
I'm 54 years old.
- What?
- I'm a grandfather.
Yes, the whole nine.
Oh, that's pretty cool.
What's your story, Judy?
I'm 53 and I have
two daughters.
Well, it's a pleasure
meeting you.
It's a pleasure meeting you.
Hmm.
I didn't like what I just
saw there, but okay.
That wasn't very nice either,
them closing the elevator
door on my man.
That's life in America.
Because the first thing
you see when you see me
is a black man.
You have no idea what my
educational background is,
what my financial background
is, what my upbringing is.
So, all you know is that I'm black.
The first thing you see
when I walk in the door.
I can honestly say
the only time I was ever
afraid of being in a car
and pulling up my window was—
I don't know what you
call it in Chicago.
I think Cabrini-Green.
But it was out of safety.
Other than that,
I've never really
been afraid of black people
and I've always given everyone
the benefit of the doubt.
But I don't look at things like that.
I have a lot of black friends.
You just gotta, I don't know.
You saw it in the film.
This guy's a judge.
He's probably brilliant,
probably has money,
more money than both of us.
But yet, they looked at him
almost like he was
a second-class citizen.
And that's what I mean,
life in America.
I think like, just, what hurts me
is seeing a lot of black people
hurting their own people.
Do you see any of that?
Well, I do see that.
But always
remember this, Judy.
People hurt the people
that they live around.
So I also know from statistics
that white people hurt and kill
and fight other white people
in their areas
because that's
who they're around.
So, when I hear about
black-on-black crime,
I get it because I see it.
I'm right outside of Chicago.
But I also know if you go
into certain areas
where there's predominantly
white people,
they hurt each other, too.
If you were in a situation where
someone pulled a gun on you,
no matter what color,
and you pull your gun out,
is that trying to protect yourself
or is that you trying
to kill somebody?
No, that's self-defense.
You see, the problem what—
the reason why we're probably
on this line right now
is because what you've seen
and I'm sure you've seen
on the news
if you've talked
to your black friends
and they really talk to you,
then you'll know that there's
black people unarmed
that are being killed by police.
Sometimes it's unprovoked.
Sometimes it's just because
the police officer
"feared for his life",
but there was really
nothing to fear.
You know, because
the person was unarmed.
Like, if you look at what
happened to George Floyd
or look at Eric Garner or look
at Jonathan—
I could go on
a laundry list of
black people
that were killed
that were unarmed.
And I always say,
"Well then damn,
that could have been me."
The problem we have
as black people,
we can't have a bad day
with the police.
You know, I can do
like you could do.
You could say, "Hey, get the
hell out of my face, you pig.
Why'd you pull me over?"
You could do that
and get away with it.
I've seen it.
I can't do that.
The minute I even say, Judy,
if I say, "Well, why'd
you pull me over?"
"You questioning me?
Get out the car."
I've seen it.
It's like they're waiting for
me to say the wrong thing
so that they
could do the wrong
thing and this thing escalates.
That's why I always use that
term, de-escalation, Judy,
because it doesn't have
to get that way.
What I'm learning is right,
wrong or indifferent;
no one is respecting
the police force.
There's some bad ones in
there, but they're not all bad.
So, what's kind of scary
for me is going forward,
who wants
to join the police force?
They're damned if they do and
they're damned if they don't.
You know, George Floyd.
He had a laundry list
of bad crimes.
Trust me and believe in me,
that guy should not have done
what he done.
What I don't like or
what I don't agree with
if you don't mind me saying
and help me understand this,
is to use him as a martyr.
We never said that
George Floyd was our hero.
We just know
that he died needlessly
and this death was the catalyst
that sparked this movement.
He wasn't combative.
He was subdued.
He was already in cuffs and
surrounded by police officers.
Yeah, and he was on drugs.
Well, see he could have
been on a lot of drugs,
but when you saw him
at that point
where that officer's knee
was on his neck,
there was no struggling.
Sure.
There was no wailing
or hidden fighting.
He was already in cuffs,
correct, Judy?
Absolutely.
Okay.
And this is why and
I'm not getting on you
because I hear this all the time.
Whenever one of us dies
at the hand of the police
or a vigilante,
we'll come up with something
that Trayvon Martin smoked reefer
or Eric Gardner shouldn't have
been selling loose cigarettes.
You'll hear every type of way
to justify those deaths.
And that's why I'm going,
you see my thing to you is,
even if he was on drugs.
I think some people
are under the impression
that we're idolizing
some of these people
as heroes when we're not.
We're really more focused
on the incident
and the injustice
of the incident
then the person, their
background, how it happened
versus kind of why
it could have happened
or what their background was
because to us
it's two different avenues.
My question to you is,
what do police officers do?
And not in this case,
because obviously this guy
and he's charged with murder
and that's the
way it should be.
They are up against
a lot of bad people.
And now they're afraid
to defend themselves
because as soon as they do,
they're ridiculed for it.
All we want them to do
is give us the same
opportunity to surrender
and comply that they do
with white people.
Let me give you
a couple of instances.
If you remember,
a guy named Dylann Roof
shot up nine black people
in a church.
They took him
to Burger King alive.
The Aurora killer who killed
the people in the theater,
they took him alive.
I got a young man
by the name of Tamir Rice,
12 years old in Ohio.
They pull up on him within
less than two seconds, Judy,
that 12-year-old
young man was dead.
So, my question is,
well, how did you not give
him a chance to comply?
"Get on the ground,
throw your weapon down."
You could have did that
from the PA.
So, all we want
is the same respect
and the same type
of compassion
and a chance to surrender.
Give me a chance
to at least go,
"Sir, I'm not doing anything.
Let me live
and I can plead my case."
I understand what you're saying.
I think that the examples
that you're using,
you're giving me a few.
There are more examples
of black-on-black crime
than what you're giving
me right now.
Wow.
And it's true.
Black-on-black crime
is over the top.
I can give you all type of
examples if you want me to.
I feel if they can stop doing
that to each other,
I truly believe things
would be better.
I wanted to interject because
I've said this to people
and I want
to get your take on it.
Black people know that
gang bangers, drug dealers
and thieves kill and rob people.
We don't get when police do it.
You see? That's the difference.
Like, if you want to talk
about black-on-black crime.
I got you. It's a problem.
It's an issue, but I don't
expect a police officer
to be that gun wielding
and shooting me down
like the gang banger did.
Like, I can't win.
I'm going to be honest with you.
I didn't see the whole thing.
It was disturbing enough
what the first police officer did.
I'll say this.
The other police officers
should have said,
"We have him.
He's under cuff, let's go."
That's wrong in my mind.
What they did was wrong.
Like, they should
have stopped him
and put him in the court
system to defend himself.
I believe that.
But I also believe
that not every white cop
out there is a bad person
and only wants
to kill black people.
Like, I don't believe that.
I think they try to do their job
and it's gotten
a lot difficult to do that
because of these situations.
So, I understand that,
but I also know that they need
to step up like you just said.
If they see a wrong doing,
they need to step up.
What you're seeing on
the news is the filming of it.
There's a bunch of black
people getting beat up, killed,
choked out and abused
that you will never see
because it wasn't taped.
But this has been going on
for decades.
We've been being beaten
and locked up for no reason
and the whole nine.
But now we're seeing it
more on tape.
There's always an epidemic
or a protest or something
right before an election.
I think that has something
to do with it.
Black people are getting
killed all the time.
It doesn't happen
just in an election year.
When Sandra Bland
or Trayvon Martin
or Eric Gardner
or Freddie Gray.
Like, these things
are happening
every several months, right?
You see it on the news.
So, it has nothing to do
with an election cycle.
This just happened to happen
at, you know, during this time,
but what's to stop something
from happening in October,
right before the November election?
- Oh, it's going to.
- It makes no sense.
You know why
it's going to, Judy?
I absolutely believe it will.
Because it happens so often,
we can almost predict it'll be
another video that comes out
at some point of somebody
getting dragged around
or beaten around.
Why now? Like, why?
Because there's no excuse now.
But it made
even white people say,
"He was not resisting arrest.
He was already in handcuffs.
There were
multiple cops around."
This was the one that
you couldn't deny.
Like, you could go,
"Well, Trayvon this.
Eric Gardner wasn't in cuffs, yet.
Rodney King wasn't in cuffs,
yet. They were still a threat."
That's all I hear.
All I hear from my
counterparts, white people,
they always can find
a way to say,
"Well, you know, he bad guy."
With this one, even though
George Floyd might have had
a background and history,
when he was being killed
as you even pointed out,
he was subdued on his
stomach, in cuffs, surrounded.
He wasn't going anywhere.
So, for him to die that way,
even the majority of everybody
who saw that tape,
I don't know too many people
that wouldn't agree with me
because at the end of the day
if you're unarmed
and you weren't really
a threat, you should be alive.
So, if they look me up and I'm
driving and they pull me over,
they're going to find out I
have a concealed carry permit.
Okay.
How do you think they should
interact with me at that point?
Do you have a concealed
weapon on you?
Yes or no?
You say, "Yes, sir, I do.
It's right here."
Okay, you're being honest.
They're being honest.
Hey, Judy, you remember
Philando Castile?
Philando Castile was
in another Michigan resident,
had a concealed carry permit.
He's not even driving.
His girlfriend's driving.
Tells the cop, "I have
a concealed carry permit.
When I reach inside this glove
compartment, you know,
you're going to see the weapon,
but this is where my insurance
and registration is."
He opens up
the glove compartment,
cop puts one right into his heart.
- And he was honest and open.
- There's a bad one.
See, but that's our thing.
Like, even when
we're honest and open
and totally transparent, we catch it.
Okay, let me ask you a question.
Who should police the police?
The citizens,
the same people that are
putting mayors in their seats,
chief of police in their seat.
All you have to do is get what
we call a citizen's panel.
It doesn't have to be
a ton of people.
It could be six or seven people
from different backgrounds
and let them look
at the different scenarios
and say, "Okay, I think we got
a bad egg here."
Scenarios, background, education.
Like, you just want
some ordinary citizen
to start policing the police?
Don't those same ordinary citizens
act as jurors in the courtroom?
That actually scares me.
What scares us is a prosecutor
who works with the police
every single day
to prosecute crimes,
now calling himself being
unbiased and neutral
policing that police officer
that killed my son.
Because of course
you're not really neutral.
You're not non-biased.
You work with guy every day.
You guys do coffee, go bowling.
How do I know you're going
to give me justice for my kid?
We gotta do better.
We can do better.
We just gotta figure out
the system to put in place
to make and hold people
accountable
and force them to do better,
because we can't keep
doing this. We can't.
I agree.
What I got out of this
whole conversation
is two people both believe
things are wrong or right,
things need to be fixed.
And I believe we had
a really good conversation.
And coming up
with a good solution
from learning from Martin.
Yeah, and I feel
that this conversation
was beneficial also
because now I get a chance
to kind of see
where people are coming
from outside of my community.
And I want to thank Judy
for her time taking part
in this conversation,
being open and honest with us
because it was great.
Thank you, Martin.
I agree.
It was really good.
Nice to meet you and hope
to talk to you again.
Nice to meet you, too.
It was a pleasure.
- Thank you.
- You, too.
I don't know where to start
with this one, Freddie.
I think that there is a whole
lot to unpack here
and I am, you know,
grateful for the opportunity.
Because I think
we checked a lot.
This conversation
checks a lot of the boxes
that are... on popular belief
and on websites
and comment threads.
So, firstly, I would like
to point out we all know it.
The go-to distracting move
when talking about putting its
boot on the neck of citizens
if those citizens happen to be
black is the ever-distracting,
what about black-on-black crime?
I would say that whenever you're on
a topic in a conversation
and the other people needs
to change the subject,
they are conceding the point.
Yes.
As Martin rightly points out,
crime is proximate.
Okay?
People eat, drink, worship,
often work in proximity
to where they dwell.
So, there's that 85 percent
of white people are killed
by the hands
of other white folks.
There's very little difference
in terms of those stats.
Again, George Floyd's murder
as they were talking about,
there was no black-on-black
crime involved.
You're just as
effective talking
about how ham sandwiches
are made.
She also, I want to know what
you think about the default,
"I have black friends" move.
Classic, classic.
What does that mean?
When do we employ that?
When we're talking
about sexual assault.
Oh, well my sister is a woman.
That has nothing to do
with what we're talking about.
Is there some early elements
of the conversation
that stood out to you?
Before we even jump into this,
I just want to say how
important it is to really see
some of these conversations
play out in real time.
Yeah.
Because you mentioned
echo chambers earlier
and how we all are
sort of you know
are inundated with
our own echo chambers.
And it's all down to like
who we follow on Instagram,
who we follow on Twitter,
our news sources.
Like, everything
is pretty much
like in line with, I think,
our worldviews.
And so you know when you see
things floating around like,
"Well, what about
black-on-black crime?"
And, well, "You know,
he was on drugs
so that's why it was okay,"
you know, things like that.
Those are all just kind of
like whispers
in the air for me
because I don't surround
myself with people
who speak that
way or who talk
about these
topics in that way.
So, to see it play out in real
time like this with
Judy and Martin
was honestly really
enlightening to me.
It was very triggering,
you know,
throughout multiple parts
of the conversation,
but I was like wow,
like these really, you know,
people really
have these beliefs
and are passionate
about them.
It's not only like, "Well, I
don't really know the answer,
but like this is what I think."
It's like, no Judy was very,
very confident in her outlook
and on her view
with these scenarios.
And so it was just, you know,
it was really interesting
to also watch Martin
so gracefully, you know,
give his point of view.
If I took anything from this
conversation,
it's just how to be— it was
how to graceful and patient.
This is a perfect example
of the role that bias can play
and the connective thread
between a simple bias
and the loss of life and
violence upon someone else.
If I am predisposed,
if I have been taught,
indoctrinated is a better word,
to believe that black people
are more prone to violence,
black men are more prone
to violence,
they're more likely
to be criminals,
which is to say less worthy
of the rights which
they are promised
and pay taxes
for and its woven
into the fabric of this nation.
If they're more likely
to be violent,
then when I see an example
or really not see anything.
When I hear somebody
on a comment thread
say they had a criminal history,
I'm more likely to make
that pathology
to be violent offenders
when in the history
of the world
clearly there is no one close
to as violent as the white
male or white society.
It's not even close.
When you hear a new word,
you start hearing
that word everywhere.
So, you're antennas only up
for specific dog whistles,
specific catch phrases,
specific terms and visuals.
So, she has this little
mini-box of five clichés
and three sentences
that just rotate.
Well black-on-black crime.
Well, that doesn't apply here.
Okay, but he had drugs in his
system and he did crime before.
Okay.
Give me a list of crimes
that are punishable
by spontaneous public execution.
There are none.
We have system
of law and order.
You said we should follow it.
We should let the system
take its course.
Why aren't we doing
that when their skin is dark?
When white violence
doesn't count,
but black violence can
be amplified at any moment,
when black life never matters
because its value
can be snatched away
in a second with a Tweet,
but white value is perpetual
because its best effort,
it always has value whether
you're shooting up a school
or a church,
you're given
the benefit of the doubt.
It's a really tough
mountain to climb
and Martin did
an excellent job trying.
But I'm glad that we have
this conversation on display
where you really have to be open
at the beginning
of a conversation
to learn something.
Yeah, absolutely.
And I think, too, Professor
L'Pree had sort of flagged
the term "aversive racism"
which I think is really
evident in this conversation
with Judy and Martin
which is aversive racism
is the lack of contact
with a group
creates stereotypes, right?
And so, I think it's pretty
clear that like, you know,
Judy says that
she has black friends, right.
That does not mean
that she has made a habit
of surrounding herself with
people who are unlike her own
in order to learn
and sort of break down
some of those stereotypes
throughout life.
So, you know she was saying
that after The Look,
after they watched The Look
she was saying, "You know,
I've never rolled up my windows
or locked my door except for
when I was in Cabrini-Green."
Safety.
Yeah, for safety, right.
And I think, too,
white people really like to,
instead of saying
black neighborhoods,
they'll say, high-crime areas
which is just code
for black neighborhoods
because of redlining
and because of the history
of this country
in really segregating
these communities
in ways that black people
specifically cannot control.
So I think that was something
that really stood out to me.
There was just so many points.
You know, I think that we could
talk about this conversation,
you know, for hours
because there's just so much
to unpack here.
But I think Martin did a really
good job of drawing parallels
to white criminals
and how they're treated
versus how black suspects
are treated.
And I think one of the quotes
that stood out to me the most
was, "Give us a chance
to surrender",
like they did Dylann Roof.
I want to just try
to put it concisely
what Judy is a
real example of...
is how your bias can come
to any case
and remix and repurpose
the entire experience.
If my bias for an unarmed,
handcuffed man on the ground
is, "Well, he was violent."
Yeah, but not this time.
"Well, he had a history."
Yeah, but that wasn't
part of this.
"Yeah, but he could have."
If you're lobbing,
we weaponize our bias.
It gives a pre-checklist instead
of actually being present
and letting that person be
a human being.
It really is worthy of examination.
And we have folks just
like her in our family,
a lot of us do.
And that is where there's
a real opportunity
to break some new ground here
because what are you without,
as Toni Morrison said, "What
are you without your racism?
Are you any good?
Is there a reason
you're hiding from it?
What are you without it?
What if we can actually just
talk about these individuals?"
That's the challenge.
So, for our next pairing,
we're going to be joining Eric
who's based in Florida.
And Danielle
who's based in Illinois.
And you guys, I was really
nervous going into this one,
so tune in.
Hi, Eric.
Hi. Hi, Danielle.
I just saw your name
pop up there.
How are you?
I'm great. How are you?
I am well.
So, what do you do for work?
I am in education.
So, I teach at a law school
and I'm a lawyer by trade.
Oh, so I gotta watch
what I say.
- No, that's awesome.
- No. Please don't.
That's awesome.
I've been a cop for 20 years.
Okay.
So, my least favorite place
is the courthouse.
Don't feel intimidated
by the space.
Oh, please let him
be the judge.
[chuckles]
Now, I love it.
That gave me chills.
I like that.
I was taken by this black man
kind of going
about his everyday life
and experiencing what
I would call micro aggressions
just from the look.
And people automatically
having certain opinions
or thoughts
about that individual.
And, you know, changing
their demeanor
because of just seeing him as
a black man or black person.
You see that happen.
You know, people who drive
through neighborhoods
and lock the doors.
If you lock them because
it's a high crime area, okay.
If you lock them because you
see somebody just walking,
totally different.
You know one thing
that troubles me, Eric,
sometimes is seeing
the different ways
in which officers have
handled black offender,
I guess I'll call it an offender.
A black offender
versus a white offender
and how white offenders can,
you know, honestly cut
the complete fool
and still be arrested
where, you know,
black folks just don't have
that kind of experience.
And they end up harmed often
and sometimes dead.
It's not acceptable what the
officers historically have done,
but I also, looking at the
sheer number of encounters
you know that hey,
not all of them are bad.
Eric, what is it like to be
a police officer right now?
It's horrible.
Because we get judged
and this is going
to sound very familiar,
by what others have done.
I understand as a police officer
this is kind of, you know,
this is unfortunate.
You know, one of the things
I would say
about the George Floyd situation
is there were officers that
were surrounding him, right?
And none of those officers
did anything.
And I'm not saying that
every one police is like that
but what I am saying is
it seems like when officers
see something wrong,
there is this kind
of code of silence.
Like, you know, I'm not going
to do anything about it.
And I think that also impacts
the perception of police officers.
If more officers said,
"We will not stand for this.
This is not acceptable.
We do not want
to perpetuate discrimination.
We don't want
to perpetuate racism.
That is not who we are
and what we are about
as opposed to kind of holding
on to that themselves."
But not stepping up
and, you know,
and breaking that code of silence.
Oh, I agree.
I think some of the things
that stop officers
from saying something
is that if the person
they observe doing it
is a senior officer,
they think well I'm a junior
officer, what do I know?
Or if they're of higher rank,
well, one day I want
to be to their rank
so I want them
on my good side.
When these type
of horrific events
go on in other parts
of the country,
we talk about it because
the best thing we can do
is to not have
it happen to us.
But it's to talk about,
well, why did this happen?
How can we keep
from this happening here?
So, regarding the incidents
around George Floyd,
I haven't seen enough to say,
of the entire video to say
that officer did that to that
man because he was black.
What I've seen was an officer
who had a subdued subject
who was not flailing around
on the ground,
keep his knee
and obstruct his airway
from what I observed
and there was no need for that.
I hear you and understand the
perspective of the department,
but I would just—
I really challenge that
because I think that, you
know, we're talking about bias.
And people have biases and
police officers have biases.
I just find it hard to believe
that had he been a white man
or even a white and certainly
a white woman,
the officer directly involved
with the knee on his neck
as well as the officers
that were surrounding,
that were standing
there looking on
would have handled it that way.
Can you imagine that officer
having his knee
on a white woman's neck
like that for 10 minutes?
That would not have
happened, right?
I'm going to tell you,
I agree that do I think
that I would see it
as a white lady
and the officer knee?
No. I agree with you.
But you look at the Orlando
police sergeant.
She was a black female.
She got murdered
by a black suspect,
but there was no Black Lives
Matter movement for that
and that's what frustrates
me is you don't see
the outcry of police officers
getting shot and killed.
And sometimes I scratch
my head and I wonder.
I'm like why is that?
People have kind of
misunderstood
that Black Lives Matter was
an affirmation directly related
to black people being killed
by the police.
If you are an officer and that
is your line of work,
there's a potential
that someone
you know may harm you,
may kill you whether they're
black, white of what have you.
But the expectation
in terms of on the flipside,
if you are a citizen
is that you will not be killed
by the police.
You know, like you said.
We sign up.
We put on a badge, a gun
and we go to the work with
the expectation to come home,
but the reality is you may not.
And a large part of me
feels extremely sad
that the Black Lives Matter
movement
has got intertwined with
rioters because that's not it.
There's a big difference
between protesting
and rioting.
You know, black folks are
an oppressed community.
And we've been oppressed
for the 400 years
that we've been here.
And, you know, slavery,
all kinds of policies
that negatively affected our lives
and our abilities
to live the American dream.
People have
to understand the history
to really understand why those
feelings are so deep seated.
When I think about, you know,
what happened in Tulsa
and what happened
in Rosewood where, you know,
black people who were
sustaining their communities
and were thriving economically
were bombed and slaughtered
by white people.
We have to keep in mind
all of these experiences
so when you're looking
at these people out there
who are protesting peacefully,
who are rioting,
who are looting,
I think that it's all a combination
of just that frustration
however it went down,
it's gotten the attention
that its needed to get.
So, I know that I'm anti-looting,
but I'm pro-protesting.
Okay, so why loot?
And I said, okay, because
I've heard people say,
"We'll they're stealing,"
the looters are stealing
from the communities
which they live in.
And then I saw something
else that said,
"Property can be replaced,
lives can't."
So, then that got me thinking.
So, if I'm a looter, other
than just personal greed,
I'm stealing from a store.
The store typically has insurance.
So, the store will be made whole,
but I'm getting my media
attention like you said.
I'm getting, you know,
I'm getting noticed
whether it's good or bad
I'm getting noticed.
As much as I don't
agree with it,
the insurance
companies pay out.
Well, if you're paying out more
money than you're bringing in,
that's a problem for business.
That's a problem for the COOs,
the CEOs and who runs them?
Typically powerful white men.
How do they get in business?
Who do they know?
Typically politicians.
So, do I try to look at as
that, that a looter is saying,
"This is the only way
I can get the powerful
person's attention,
white, black, Hispanic,
typically white,
if you look at the makeup
of congress,
this is how I get their attention."
Do I agree with it?
Absolutely not.
Have I tried to
understand it? Yes.
That's great that you
have tried to understand
and just broaden
your perspective on it.
The recourse that people have
to change unjust systems
is protesting, advocating,
doing policy work
and trying to get
to the root causes
of some of these issues,
so people are in the streets.
They're angry.
They're rioting because
they're trying to get awareness
and attention to this issue
because for so long they've gone
through these different
kind of measures of change
and recourse without action
really being taken
or without action taken to the
extent that it needs to be done.
To tell people
how they should protest
and what they should do
and what's appropriate
and what's not appropriate
I think is out of line.
This country was founded
by people who protested.
You know, the Boston Tea Party
and all of these things,
they looted and tore
things up and so on,
you know the feeling of desperation,
the feeling of not having
is what pours
into the looting part of it
or the rioting part of it.
One of the things I'd love to see
is not just, hey we're here
and we want change,
but what is acceptable.
Now the new thing is
the disbanding and defunding
of police departments
is the pushing.
What does a real reform
look like?
What does defunding a police
department look like?
The core that is about money.
Since we're paying them,
we want accountability.
If money from policing
is diverted to education,
you know, wouldn't that
be helpful for the police?
I like that because
it makes me go,
okay so it's maybe not a
hundred percent a bad thing.
What can I do to say this is
a step in the right direction?
One thing is just kind of
being educated on these issues.
You know, there's all kinds
of ways to address,
to learn about bias
because we all have them.
And there are not more officers
that are stepping up to say no.
This is not how these
situations should be addressed.
And this is, you know,
this is a result of, you know,
a bias or whatever it is,
but officers taking
on this issue.
I agree that you have got
to have a sense of this
is the job you want to do.
Don't let anybody call
anything into question.
Do the right thing
all the time.
Thanks, Eric, for this opportunity
and joining in this very
important conversation
that needs to be had.
We need that.
We are all dependent on
each other for, you know,
having some actionable
things take place.
We know that
there is a process
that needs to get started.
But what I can tell you is
I certainly appreciate you.
You represent the
City of Chicago very well
so they should be very proud
because I am a better person
for spending the last couple
of hours with you.
Thank you, same here.
So, one of the first things
that jumped out at me
in this conversation
just at the outset,
I just want to have
a through line
that several of these other
conversations we have seen
this through line of one
of the participants reacting
to The Look video
by mentioning
whether they like it or not,
whether they agree
with it or not.
And man, Eric really took me
on a journey there sometimes
where my assumption based
on what he does for a living
as a Deputy Sheriff
or maybe just the direction
of his language sounded
like he was going
to land somewhere
but he kind of took us
on a ride
and actually had been
quite thoughtful about,
he kind of took us through
behind the curtain
as to how he processed things
and weighed pros and cons
in an interesting way that was
a little more fleshed out
than I think folks often do.
So, I actually appreciated
that a couple of times
in the conversation
around has he broke down
the rationale
or end result of so-called looting.
Yeah, yeah.
I think, too, something that
jumped out
from jump in this video
was that as soon
as Danielle told him
and revealed
that she's a lawyer,
you could sort of see
Eric's reaction to that.
And I think that, you know,
I think he was a little
bit intimidated
By the fact that she's a lawyer
and they would be engaging
in this conversation about bias.
And so, I do wonder
and if she had
a different occupation
or if he a little bit
more comfortable
and less like feel like
he needed to stay on his toes,
would he have spoken to her
or spoken about this topic
in the same way?
Eric made a distinction
between pro-protesting,
"I'm against looting", but
understanding that we can't—
when we talk about policing
the major through line
is never the worst among
them as the headline.
Protesting has very little
to do with white agitation
and so-called
anarchists people
bussing themselves into protest
to obviously be destroying property
and instigating property damage.
But it detracts.
It's easily,
if you're not interested
in the subject matter,
detracts from the story.
It has to be addressed
in a dominant fashion.
It eats up time and energy
instead of talking
about the real frustration.
But he did land on an interesting
point about looting
actually being the only way to
get some people's attention.
Yeah, which was great.
It seemed like he
had really thought it through
versus just saying,
like, you know,
"These folks are taking
advantage of the situation.
They're stealing.
They're doing X, Y and Z."
Which is the way to deflect
from the actual issue at hand
and I think that it's important
that we keep calling
that out, these deflections
that keep coming up
in these conversations.
And when we are in a time
which we are now
of really having
a public conversation
about transformational change
around policing,
we're talking about
defunding the police.
People are trying to figure out
what exactly that does
and does not mean.
In order to really be present for
and active in that conversation,
you do need to understand
some of the context
that they're laying out.
So, that's a step towards saying,
okay, if this is not working in
the way it claims to be working,
if it was we wouldn't have
to talk about it.
If people felt both
protected and served,
we'd be on to
a different topic.
We defund things all the time.
We defund education,
we defund health care,
we defund public assistance.
We reduce funding in
those departments.
And I felt like Eric really
started in a good place
and that he was open
and would be open
to kind of understanding
that we actually have a lot
of these mechanisms in place
and as a police officer
I think he embodies
what a lot of deputy sheriffs
or police officers,
however you define law
enforcement in that case,
they know they're not
the ones to call for.
They're exhausted.
They know
they're not the ones
to call for mental
health crises
or when you lost your dog
or for a neighbor's arguing
with each other
about the sound or a driver
who pulled over to fall asleep.
You know, they know
they're not the one
that they're spread thin
on these issues.
And if they're only trained
to enforce criminal code with
various forms of violence,
we're doing us all a favor
by taking that off their plate
and putting that
into a safer place.
So, I was glad to see
that he was open
to kind of wrestle
with an idea
and not have an easy,
deflective quip.
Mm-hmm.
And I wanted to really quickly
just touch on the idea
of around morality as a police
officer or as a deputy sheriff
or just working in
that field in general.
One thing that stuck out to me
was Eric was saying that
when all else fails,
or, you know, if anything's
ever in question,
I teach my trainees
to always do the right thing.
And that is,
it's too broad of an idea
when people's lives are
in your hands, right.
So, it's like you
know we're sure
that the police officer who
was on George Floyd's neck
thought he was doing
the right thing.
Sure.
Your bias directly affects
what you think in that moment
is the right thing to do.
So if we're not all addressing
our biases
and because they have
the power to, you know,
really craft and mold the
outcomes of these situations,
there's a larger conversation
that needs to be had within
these police departments
because you know I mean,
it all starts with bias.
And across the board
can truly affect
whether someone lives or dies.
All right, let's dive into
our next conversation.
We have Fred calling in
from Pennsylvania
and we have
Paul from Colorado.
There we go.
Sweet.
Hey, Fred, how you doing?
Good. How are you doing, Paul?
Oh, just peachy, man.
[laughs]
Where you from?
Oh, you're a handsome lad.
[laughs] Thank you.
I am originally from Montreal.
Married with children?
I married a Puerto Rican
women two years ago.
Out of that I got a 22
and a 21 year old.
They're gorgeous kids.
Very blessed.
Good, nice.
My oldest son's an engineer
and my daughters
go to private school.
And my oldest, next oldest son
was going to private school
as well for a while.
So, we're fortunate to be able
to provide our kids with...
Yeah.
...you know,
that kind of education.
Let me intercept here
on what you just said that
"We're very fortunate
that we can do this".
What does that mean?
That means that I grew up in
a pretty rough neighborhood.
Okay.
I had very serious run-ins
with the police as a child.
I've been arrested
four times by the police.
I've been roughed up
by the police several times
and had the unfortunate experience
of burying over 50 kids
from gang violence.
And then, I had a kid die
in my arms in '91.
And so, I've known death a lot.
And so, I say fortunate
because I've been able to ascend
in the job market in our region.
I'm the first black CEO
of the company
I'm currently in charge of.
I can't relate to what
you're talking about
because where I come from,
we don't have these issues.
The biggest problem I had
growing up as a kid,
it wasn't race for me.
I grew up French, okay?
I didn't learn to really speak
English until I was 12.
Most of my education
was all in French.
But my name was English.
That caused
problems at school.
I got into a lot of fights
in the schoolyard,
allies or whatever
because I had an English name
and I lived in a French sector.
A lot of bombs were going off
in English sectors.
And my mom was very
concerned about that
because I was going to school
in an English area.
Then I ended up moving back
to Colorado in 1996
and I've been here ever since.
I can't agree to a lot
of the visuals I just saw
because that's just not who I am.
I've never been a
part of that, never will.
And so, I find it disturbing.
And I think the idea, the deep
idea has really not improved.
For me, unfortunately
I resonated very much
with the video,
in particular him being a judge.
I have some level of recognition
in the City of Pittsburgh
and so actually
I get treated differently
if I come into a place
and I'm dressed down.
People don't even speak to me,
people that have known
me for years.
And so, people are used
to this suit being me.
I would say from
a context perspective,
there has always been slavery
all around the world
for millennia.
Oh, yeah, yeah.
The kind of slavery
that took place in America
is the only one of its kind,
chattel slavery.
For 246 years,
America used black people
from the continent,
from sun up to sun down,
to create a super power
in less than 200 years.
After 246 years of slavery,
it was followed by a 135 years
of institutional racism.
Jim Crow laws, redlining,
making it illegal for blacks
to have the same benefits
of their white counterparts
even after they went to fight
in the world wars.
And now in America
we have 55 years
of alleged freedom and equity
which many of us in America
don't see that way.
And I can tell you that
my experiences
as a black man with education,
having went to school
several times,
I am challenged every day
by microaggressions.
I'm challenged when
I walk in a store.
I know that feeling
of sitting in a restaurant
and people being
directed to sit near you.
And they go,
"No, I want to sit over here."
What?
And you have to tell your child
it's okay when it's not okay.
And so, Paul,
I was very interested
and struck by your experiences
and also struck by the fact
that that video moved you
because you never had that
experience and that's not you.
But were you able
to, for a moment,
put yourself in that
person's shoes and window
and just wonder
for a brief moment
what that might feel like?
Well, let me interject here.
First of all, it's not
that it didn't move me.
It did.
It pissed me off.
You know, Fred,
I'm just not seeing
that this country as I mentioned
earlier, is really improving.
Have you ever thought about,
or had to give the talk
to your daughter
or to your new—
Son?
—children in your marriage
about any kind of interaction
where their race or beliefs
might cause them
some social discomfort or
be challenged by authorities?
If I had to have a conversation
with my kids about this,
it would be hard for me
because I wouldn't know
pretty much where to start
because I mean,
I haven't had this problem.
But you know what?
You have to because they're
being bombarded with this
24 hours a day.
How I treat and talk to my
children is very much reflective
of the environment that they
walk into every day.
One of the most
difficult conversations
I've had to have with my son
is how to conduct yourself
when the police
pulled him over
and they will get pulled over.
My most difficult conversation
was years ago
having my oldest son
drive one of my vehicles
and be pulled over by the
police and harassed physically
because he was driving
a very expensive vehicle.
Then the officer threw him up
against the vehicle
and started harassing him
about what does his father
do or mother do?
And so, you know,
that really hurt us.
What you see today
in the marching
and the sit-ins and the protesting
is really saying enough is enough.
You've had your foot
on our necks
literally for 400 years
and we're not going
to take it anymore.
Well, you know, I'm going
to say something
about the protest movements,
you know.
The change or the difference
I found is that they became—
this became global.
You know, you were having
different countries in the world
that were walking around
with banners
on what happened to George,
even my country.
Now, I've got some interesting
feelings about this looting
and all the stuff that's going
on behind the protestors
because that's not the message.
So, I think that
that's something
that might have been thrown
in the wash and tainted.
Why don't you look at the other
side of the fence, you know?
The police department,
you know, what they're dealing with.
Okay? They got a job to do,
but I think some of them
unfortunately take that badge
and the equipment that comes
with it a little too seriously.
And unfortunately,
there's a problem there.
And it's everywhere in
this country, okay?
We know.
We got a sideline of cops
that work together as a unit.
They back each other up
and they're all part
of a little clique
that sometimes causes
problems like this.
And they feel because
they have this uniform
they can take all this authority.
One of the things I honor
about people
is when people are transparent
and fully vulnerable
and I think that's something
that men in particular struggle with.
Our bravado, our disposition,
the things people expect us
to do and focus on.
It really has created a false
sense of control for us.
And so, you know, Paul,
I feel like we come
from two different sides
of the world.
There's some similarities
in how we were raised.
I'll tell you
something right now
in comparison
to where we relate again,
is that growing up I didn't
have anybody to guide me.
I didn't have a father, okay.
I didn't have a father
to guide me,
to give me wisdom, to teach me
to basically even back me up.
So, my whole life as a kid,
I had like a mask on.
And I was always trying to be
something that I wasn't
because I didn't feel
I was good enough.
It's funny,
the more that you talk,
the more we have similarities.
I grew up from a broken home.
My mother and father divorced
when I was young.
Yep.
Because when you allow yourself
to listen to another
person's perspective,
you realize that many of their
experiences mirrors your own.
But when you dig deeper,
and this is implicit biases,
I can look at him
and he can look at me
and go,
"Hey, that's a black guy."
I could go, "That's a white guy."
But after an hour
and a half, two hours,
we're two different people who
happen to have one brown skin,
one white skin.
But the people who
possess those skins
are not defined by black or white.
And I think that's the importance
of having conversations
about bias and implicit bias
is that it allows us
to expand our own horizons
in a way to push us to
new levels of understanding,
appreciation and patience
that is required for us to figure out
how we're going to turn
this thing around.
I need Paul.
It's the totality of all of
our experiences that are going
to offer solutions to the
global phenomena we face.
I can just see us, you know,
bumping into each other in a bar
and we would have
this conversation.
And I'm pretty sure
you'd probably say,
"You're not from here,
are you?"
And but there should be more
people that are not from here.
When you find a kindred spirit,
it's really about honoring
their humanity in ways that
allows the DNA of the exchange
to the conversation to live
in a part of you
so that you always honor
the person who moved you
or filled your vessel
with a different fluid
that allows you
to have more diversity of
thought, action and beliefs.
So, I appreciate that
and thank you.
As I would say,
"A la prochaine fois, mon ami,"
which means,
"Until next time, my friend."
Oui.
As long as you don't say it twice.
That means,
"You gotta go somewhere".
All right, man.
Love you, buddy.
All right, love you, man.
Appreciate you.
- Take care.
- Yes, sir.
- Okay, bye-bye.
- Bye-bye.
Well, that was a cute little
ending to a conversation.
I felt like they had this like
really beautiful camaraderie
and almost like
a brotherhood by the end
which was really
refreshing and nice to see.
Just a reminder you guys,
these are strangers.
This was their first time
ever speaking to
and meeting one another.
So the fact that they were
able to share experiences
and sort of compare
and contrast
and then you know end it
on such a really loving note,
was really nice.
Yeah.
It was sweet.
I think that
it's also an example
because they're
very different.
They have very different
experiences as were highlighted
through the conversation
which we'll talk about
and some presuppositions
and misunderstandings
of different understandings of reality.
But what it does show
is really for me the value
of these conversations
because you start
where you are.
It doesn't matter if you have 15
or 55, you start where you are
in terms of in terms
of exposure
and wrestling
with new ideas
being challenged
on your position.
There is no too early in this case
we're talking about adults
to have these conversations.
And I feel like Fred
challenged Paul
on a lot of his presuppositions.
We talked about
the aging up of black youth.
This making them—
you know, we've had studies
that demonstrate
that there's after about nine,
10 years old
black minors become adults,
they get older than
the way they actually are
to make them more threatening.
They are inflated.
Their persona has inflated
to make it more
dangerous, menacing,
easy to be described as a threat.
These are things that
Paul was familiar with,
but whenever
he gets exposed to it,
he will be forever changed.
You can't unsee and unlearn
historical context.
So that's really one
of the beautiful things
about having these
conversations.
I want to quickly jump
into the idea of parenting
and sort of the difference
between, you know,
how white people are
raising their children
versus how black people
are raising their children
and the conversations,
and how the conversations
differ, right?
So, Paul was saying, you know,
he wouldn't even know
where to start in terms of
having these conversations
with his kids about racism,
about bias, about prejudice
and how to be more
aware of your own
so that you can make
the lives of others,
who are different
from you, better,
like help them have a little
bit more of a better day
than they may have
previously experienced
before coming in contact
with them.
But then Fred was saying
like after watching The Look
he was like,
"Oh yeah, you know,
I can completely relate
to all of these scenarios.
I've had the elevator
door shut on me."
People have locked their
doors when I've walked by
and, you know,
and he wears suits for work.
So, he notices a real
difference in how he's treated
when he's wearing suits
and then when he's out
with his kids
and these microaggressions
happen.
He has to sort of,
you know, lay low,
not get too, you know,
visually upset
and sort of to calm the situation
and to deescalate it,
tell his kids,
"You know, it's okay.
It's not a problem"
when it is a problem.
And I think that
that's something
that I think that you know
I can absolutely relate to
in terms of just sort of that,
you know, how I was raised
versus I think, you know,
how some of my white
counterparts were raised
who don't really
deal with that.
Yeah, it's exhausting to have
to consistently pace yourself
and be able to make it—
do I use all my energy
on this now?
Do I change the whole
experience in the room
or do I want to just get out
of here and take a breath
and deal with it
in the car or later?
The degree to which
we don't have control
over the onslaught,
control over when the
wave is going to crash on us
and what a luxury it is
to just not ever have
to be confronted with this
or have to talk to your
family about it
and just being able
to go about your life
pursuing your dreams
and interests.
And whether the realities
of our experience
is not for you to agree.
It's not a matter of agree
or disagree.
It's a matter of do I care or
do I not, and being interested.
I think a big takeaway for me
was also sort of had to do
with the short film The Look.
And, you know,
black man walking through
the world being mistreated.
And then the reveal at the end
is that he's a judge.
But I think something
to really highlight here
is that even
if he was not the judge,
even if he was the bailiff or
even if he was the custodian,
he still does not deserve
to be treated
in any of those ways.
Even if people who belong in
marginalized communities
are not stand-up citizens
or aren't heroes,
they still deserve respect
and they still deserve to go
home at the end of the day.
Decency, fairness and freedom
does not have to be re-earned
every time a black person
steps outside of their house
when white people
just get to be white.
All right.
Let's go into
this conversation,
which really
stood out to me.
This is between Kaylah
who calls in from New York
and Angela calling
in from California.
They're some gems.
Hi.
I'm Angela.
I'm Kaylah.
- Nice to meet you.
- You too.
I feel like I have experienced
the look my whole life
in high education,
in predominately white spaces,
like people assuming
I don't belong somewhere
or wondering
why I am somewhere.
For me what really stood out
is having these stares.
And while I didn't grow
up with that—
actually growing up
it was quite the opposite,
no one seeing me
as an Asian American.
And then now,
in the time of COVID-19,
we go from invisibility
to hypervisibility.
So when I walk out that door
I am hypervigilant of the ways
in which I take up space.
If I sneeze, is someone
going to give me a dirty look?
Are people going to scoot back
when they see me
because I'm Asian?
And we too have been hurt
by systemic injustice.
Yeah.
Everyone has their own biases,
everyone is biased in some way
about something or somebody,
and then the line between just
being biased and being racist
is like what you do after that.
I think it's important
to talk about bias
because it dispels any taboo
or stigma there is.
When you name it,
when you call it out,
when you know what it is,
it kind of flashes a light on it.
It can no longer hide in the dark.
For my undergrad Capstone project
I did a case study
on this woman.
This black woman
who was in jail
and she was pregnant
and she died in jail
because she had
an ectopic pregnancy
and the officers and the
nurses didn't help her.
The other inmates
were saying like,
"Hi, can you hear her,
she's like dying?"
and nobody did anything.
But in doing more research
we see that those same guards
and nurses in that same jail
15 years earlier let the
same exact thing happen
to another black women
from the same exact cause.
When you're saying
that too with the whole—
kind of the health disparities
between black and
brown communities,
I'm thinking about the father
of gynecology
perfected his fistula
operation on slave women
without anesthetics.
Something that we talked about
a lot in my classes
and in my extracurricular
during my Master's
was that this kind
of like general idea
that black children, and black
women, girls in particular,
kind of seen
as older than they are
and seen as like being able
to withstand pain.
I think a lot of our
understanding of this comes,
you know, growing up, is
obviously in our history books.
And they don't talk
about stuff like this
and they kind of paint the
whole civil rights movement
as like, oh, Dr. King came
and he fixed racism,
Rosa Parks fixed racism and
now we're good, you know,
and kids are kind of growing
up and they're like, you know,
they see these things happen
and are like, wait,
but I thought like racism is fixed.
- No.
- Yeah.
The first person to do
the Rosa Parks thing
I guess and not get off
the bus was this young,
dark-skinned girl
who was pregnant,
but they didn't want her to be
the face of the movement.
There's so many facets
of bias and racism
within communities even,
not just between communities.
My dad, he's very light-skinned
and I tried to tell him one time
that colorism is a thing
and light-skinned
privileges is a thing
and he was like,
"No it's not.
When I go to places,
people will respect me
because I'm me."
And I was just like,
"Okay but"—
he almost couldn't recognize
that if we were
to go someplace,
we wouldn't get
the same reaction
because like me being
a darker-skinned black woman
and him being
a lighter-skinned man,
not only is there the
lighter-skinned privilege,
but also just you being a man.
In a lot of spaces
that holds a lot of weight.
I have also had a few conversations
regarding, I guess just like
microaggressions.
One conversation was
with my supervisor
because I experienced some
microaggression at work.
And he is a white male.
He's in his 50s.
And first thing he says is,
"Angela, you know,
I will never be able to
understand your experience.
I recognize that I am a white male,
but can you help me understand?"
And I literally broke down
when he said that
because it was such a place
of humility, that he took
and I strongly believe
that like the person
in the conversation
in the room,
that has the least power,
should not be the person
to bring up
the hardest topic, right?
And I think that
he created a space
where he recognized that
and he kind of lowered
himself to elevate me.
I love that story.
My question for you
would also be like how does
your community—
and I'm speaking specifically
black community—
view Asian Americans?
I have personally seen
and experienced
a fair amount of racism from—
I don't want to say the Asian
community but specific people,
but I've also experienced
the opposite.
But I do think that,
in particular when
traveling abroad,
it's like something that
I think about a lot,
just the way that
anti-blackness is everywhere.
And, again, I don't think this
is just in an Asian thing;
I think a lot
of non-black communities
want to have
the benefits of blackness,
but none of the other stuff
that comes with it,
none of the negative things
that come with it.
I think that there is
a history of strife
between the Asian community
and the black community
and I think a lot of it is designed.
The model minority, that term,
that model minority term
was created by white people
as a way to perpetuate
anti-blackness.
What the model minority myth
is basically a term
that white people have
created, saying that Asians,
you know, look
how hard-working they are.
They are a group of people
that can pull themselves up
by the boot straps.
Look how successful
they can be in our society.
And then kind of pit that
against the black community
and be like why aren't you
doing anything?
If this group of immigrants
can do this, why can't you?
To only justify
like they're position of like,
oh, we're not racist;
you're the problem.
Yeah.
So I think we must
understand that,
how we've been used
in that way,
like weaponized, you know,
against the black community.
We have this like perpetual
foreigner status.
We are a model minority until
you're a perpetual foreigner.
It's kind of like the idea
of like pet to threat.
Like we're good with you
until like corona virus happens
and you're a threat,
like your yellow peril.
Yeah, wow, yeah.
In kind of the beginning
of the pandemic I guess,
I had like a little bit
of a heated conversation
with a friend of mine
because he had been
in Shanghai for work
and when he came back
his coworker said something
like, "I hope you didn't bring
anything back,
we're going to have
to separate
one of the Asian
American employees."
And he told me about it
later and I said,
"Okay, so what did you say?"
And he said, "Nothing."
And I was so upset
because in that moment
that person has enough
either respect for you
or has enough
of a relationship with you
to tell a joke like that,
then it's on you to use that position
to say, "Hey, this is not okay."
It's just unacceptable at this point
to not speak up about things,
especially when the other
person is not in the room
to defend themselves.
I feel like you can't choose
when to be like antiracist
because all these issues
are connected
and all of these issues
affect real human beings.
How do you think
Asian Americans
can show up for black lives
in an Asian American way,
however you perceive that?
For a start, I would just say like
using your own voice
to speak out generally
and then also recognizing
the privilege
that some people have to benefit
from black culture and blackness
but not have any
of the bad implications of it.
And then also when you're
elevated to a certain level,
making space for other people
like you in that level;
whether you're a woman
in the boardroom,
make room for other women
in those spaces or make room
for other people of color
in those spaces
I think is important.
I think often times
the racial discourse
has been under a binary
of black and white
and that kind of renders
people in-between
as feeling invisible
or feeling irrelevant
to the discourse.
And I think that's
why a lot of people
feel like they can't speak up
because it's always about
black and white, right?
Mm-hmm, yeah.
And so what would be helpful
is to even offer space
to non-black people of color
to have those voices too,
because there is something
unique about their experiences.
That is going to contribute
to allyship.
Just like I might expect
friends of mine
to be allies for
the black community,
I expect for myself to be an
ally for other communities,
including the Asian American
community,
including the Hispanic
Latin communities,
including any and everybody.
I really enjoyed
our conversation, Kaylah,
and like you said,
I think that we do have
a lot in common
and everything
that you were saying
my heart was like yes!
[laughs]
Even though our experiences
are different,
that feeling of not being seen,
it's like the theme
of our conversation, right?
Yeah, for sure.
Thank you for talking with me.
Yeah, thank you so much
for everything
that you've shared with me.
I think it's just something that
I really will treasure, thanks.
Bye!
I love the discussion
around women's health.
They really sort of did
a deep dive on women's health
in regards to especially
black women, in particular,
and how our bodies have been
used for centuries
within the medical field to test
and to prod and pry
and figure things out.
And specifically from the
"Father of Gynecology,"
J. Marion Sims,
he was perfecting his process
on black women's bodies
only to blow up
and really start this whole
sector of the medical field
that hadn't really
been ironed out yet.
Black women are constantly
kicked out of hospitals,
or left for dead and neglected
because they are not
only not treated
as valuable human beings,
but their symptoms must be—
that's also gendered—
because they must be hysterical
because they're women.
They're considered
to be stronger like oxen
because we're born
here as chattels,
as pieces of animals,
not human beings.
So all that stuff, all that
bias, the slightest bias,
well, I just thought
she was asymptomatic
or I thought that was
probably just indigestion.
That is fueled by a bias,
like they're less reliable people
that can't be trusted to know
themselves or others as well,
they're less mature.
Or they can handle it.
Yeah they're stronger.
Y'all, you're the face
of undying strength.
Oh absolutely.
I mean, I can say myself,
you know,
I've heard the term
time and time again
in regards to the Asian
American community
as being the "model minorities,"
that kind of thing.
And it totally makes sense,
but I never—
like the way
that she articulated
it was so eye-opening
because she was saying
that term was developed
by white people.
Absolutely.
In order to weaponize
Asian people
to really separate
the marginalized communities
from each other so that
we can't band together
and we don't feel like we are
sort of all in this together.
It's really a lot of that separation.
It's just like colorism
and slavery,
white people in having
the house slaves
and the field slaves,
really driving that friction
between these communities.
One of the things
that I'm reminded of
in this conversation
is, when I was studying
the Black Panthers
I think in high school,
and learning about Japanese
and Asian support
for the Black Panthers
and the term "yellow peril"
and seeing it in (inaudible)
one of the first examples
to me of one minority
standing up for the other.
We're used to seeing
it around gender,
sexual orientation in
this generation;
men standing up
in the Me Too movement
and people advocating
against sexual assault
or rape culture
or certainly straight cis
culture standing up
and advocating for those
in the LGBTQI community.
So we're used
to the structures there,
but in minority
community there
tends to be such isolation
which is both its strength
and, in many ways,
possibly it's a weakness
because it creates
separateness.
Yeah, yeah.
And I think it sort of brings
us back to the idea of allyship
versus appropriation
and making sure that if you
are taking and appreciating
the cool parts of certain cultures
and like the parts
that are like convenient,
that are fun right, that
you're also doing research
and you're also acknowledging
and amplifying the bad
that also goes on
within those communities
in efforts to change.
So I think it's really just
being intentional.
I think an example of that,
Freddie, that has worked
to communicate
this idea to others
is black women's hair styles
have been banned,
made unprofessional,
you can't wear them.
Or basically any hair styles
that white folks can't do
are considered unprofessional
for black women;
various braids,
dreadlocks, twists,
Bantu knots, etcetera.
They're just considered
unprofessional,
just happens to be primarily
black hair expression.
But once you start seeing
pop-culture icons that are white
or not black wearing corn rows
and they rename them
as something else
and they're on runways
for Chanel and Dior
and durags
and all these things
that we weren't allowed in
your establishment if we had
our hair that way,
if we wore Tim boots,
if we had drank this beer.
There's all types
of codified racism, right?
An example of how to be an ally
is once you get in with
that hair style
advocating that we all get in.
Yep.
If you just walk in and leave
them all out in the cold,
that's when
you're appropriating,
you're actually not
down for anything
but yourself.
Beautifully put.
Well, that completes this
round of conversations.
I think we covered
a lot of ground,
had people from all over the
country being really personal
and having really
productive conversations.
I think there's a lot
to break down.
You're doing it in the
comments of Dr. L'Pree.
And we've tried to do our part
by carrying you through
some of these things
and sharing our thoughts,
insights and experiences.
Yes.
Thank you so much
to all the participants.
This was such
a valuable experience
and hopefully all the viewers
have enjoyed it
and learned something as well,
because I definitely did.
Yeah, it does take some bravery.
I don't know if all of us would
have signed up to go in blind
for these one-on-one
conversations sight unseen
and for it to be broadcast
around the world;
a hats-off to you all
for stepping up
and being brave enough
to have some
of these conversations.
I've taken a lot from this
experience, I must say.
I think throughout
we talked about
some of the commonalities
that reared their heads,
not necessary good or bad
but in a way
that really helps us
kind of understand exactly
why we do exercises like this.
Do you have any ideas
that stuck out to you
as particularly resonant
and where people
showed some growth?
Yeah, I mean, I think everyone
walked out, hopefully-
and I really do think based
on what we were able to see,
I think everyone walked out
of this experiment
a little bit more aware
and I think that,
that is the goal.
You know, it's not
about being perfect,
it's not about not having
bias, we all have our biases.
So I think that it's really important
that you recognize them
and then what really counts
is what you do once
you recognize them
and how you sort of affect
change in the world.
I think a big take away for me
was also sort of had to do
with the short film The Look
and, you know, black man
walking through the world
being mistreated
and then the reveal at
the end is that he's a judge.
And that's what we've seen
so much of in this last year
is folks letting those
biases tumble, tumble,
until they grow so heavy
that they can't be stopped
and people just get out of control.
I'm glad that didn't happen
in any of these conversations,
so we could actually have
productive dialogue.
Really impressed by the ability
of a lot of our participants
to step up, to adjust,
to not like what they hear
but still find a way
to stay on an even keel
and have a productive conversation.
Yeah, I'm really happy
we did this, and, again,
thankful to P&G and BuzzFeed
for creating a space for it.
It's pretty damn smart.
Yes, thank you so much.
And it's been great chatting
with you, Jesse,
and just getting to know you more
and really bounce ideas off
of each other.
I mean I can't think of a better
pairing with us, you know?
Yeah, for real, for real.
Take this show on the road.
Yeah, yeah.
One of the main goals
for today's experiment
and conversation
is for you to walk away
with some more confidence,
some more tools,
some more courage
to have similar
conversations about bias
with the folks around you.
We've also created a resource
guide for how to best have
these conversations and in,
can't tress this enough,
a productive manner.
The only point is not
just an exercise
in getting your bars off.
It's about actually how can
you move the ball forward.
And it's not always the person
I would say you're talking to.
It's the others that
are listening as well.
So we've partnered
with a few organizations
that are leading the charge
in this department
and work with them
to develop a detailed plan
to help in the best ways
that we can.
And some of that
includes learning
about historical
and present-day experiences
that fuel systematic racism,
that fuel inequality,
ways that you, where you live,
wherever that is,
you can activate your local
communities directly.
You can be an ally,
an advocate, an activist.
You can certainly
be antiracist.
We've talked before
and the choice
that P&G put together
really does a good job
of illustrating
that you can't be neutral
on a moving train,
as Howard Zinn used to say.
You have to be anti-racist.
Donate to these organizations
that we've laid out that
advanced equity and justice.
There are people that are
spending their time and energy
on justice for folks,
they need our support.
And they need our money
obviously, also.
And we can't stress
that enough.
All it takes is, in life these
little pivot points,
where you're exposed
to something
that you otherwise wouldn't,
might inform a lot of designs
going forward.
So go ahead
and share the video.
You could have some really
interesting conversations,
not only for yourself
but for others.
So go ahead and click the link
on the video description
for a page with more details
on how to learn,
how to activate and donate.
Freddie, I think we came,
we saw, we learned.
I'm really pleasantly surprised.
I didn't know how
this was going to go.
I was excited about it
but I'm proud of what
we not only learned
and experienced, but shared
with each other today.
So I want to
thank you for your
time, energy, and expertise.
It really made a world
of difference.
Yes. Thank you so much.
I honestly, I mean I loved
talking about this stuff.
I could talk about it all day,
so this is not work for me.
It's definitely something that
is more than that for me,
so I'm happy to be a part
of this whole experiment
and project as a whole.
And to everyone watching,
thank you so much
for watching and stay safe,
stay loud, and create change.
That's right, peace.